My name is Lewis Kaneshiro.
I build courses here at Udacity and
I've used version control in different forms for about four years now.
Version control makes me more of a risk taker in the sense that
I'm able to explore pretty significant changes in the code base.
Architecture differences at,
at a very low level without fear of breaking the entire project.
and, and, and freaking out, you know, for
lack of a better word, to try to make it work again.
And so, without version control the way I looked at code was as soon as it
was working, I would make very small iterative changes.
Whereas with version control I, I'm able to rethink the entire code base or, or
rethink parts of them that quite honestly I wouldn't have approached or
even touched for fear of breaking it.
So, in general big picture the things I really like about version control is
really this idea of exploration.
Without version control I feel that developing as a programmer is,
is taking little baby steps of making a program incrementally better.
Whereas with version control you can explore such a large space of, of,
of things to try, and you can do that easily without really
worrying about having to go back and fix a project that's that's broken.
So I feel version control has made me a better programmer because it
allows me to explore deep concepts, deep architectural concepts within
programs that I wouldn't be able to explore easily and
more efficiently if I was not using version control.